[Musique]
ils sont maintenant 300 peut être plus
célèbres ou inconnus qui ont quitté
l'amérique ait choisi de vivre à paris
comme nocive holloway
[Musique]
à
du l'avancé ça va très bientôt
non si je vois que vous êtes en train de
répéter un enregistrement pensez-vous
que vous auriez eu en amérique le même
succès qu'en france
je ne peux pas dire parce que j'ai
jamais chanté en amérique jute et une
danseuse de ballet mais
je crois que ça a marché bien pour moi
en france parce que je suis différente
une autre type j'ai peu léger accent et
puis j'avais pas la traque quand je suis
venu en france parce que personne ne me
connaissait alors si je chante et je
faisais une bonne bien ça n'aura su
alors temps pour ça
dans le paris de la rive gauche où le
jazz a élu domicile une autre chanteuse
noire à zesco
[Musique]
les sur l'appli
qu'est ce qui vous fait rester dans ce
pays la liberté
l'amérique c'est aussi la liberté oui
mais ça dépend de la couleur votre peau
par exemple si je veux louer un
appartement dans un beau quartier en
amérique et n'importe quelle ville c'est
impossible mais en france il suffit que
j'ai de quoi p
et 1000 cadeaux les photographes comme
beaucoup d'autres il est venu chercher à
paris la possibilité d'un certain
épanouissement
vous menez à paris vous permet d'étaler
votre talent photographe oui et c'est
justement la raison que je suis venu se
trouvait qu'à new york il y avait fait
quelqu'un
raciste qui a empêché les américains de
voir mon travail voyez ma que j'étais
noir et ses enfants se trouve que je
marque ma photo et il voit et apprécié
mes photos c'est souvent autour d'une
bouteille de côtes du rhône que se
reconstituent à l'heure du dîner un
semblant d'ambiance de harlem le
cuisinier leroy n 6 a pourvu en amenant
avec lui au barbecue
mais cela relève mme l'année qu'un
fantôme car en choisissant paris ils ont
bien souvent adopté la vie à la
française comme lou williams gardin
smith le romancier en france pourquoi
avez vous justement choisi la france
j'ai quitté les états unis à cause du
racisme je trouvais que je pouvais
vraiment tous travailler là bas
je sentais une violence monte à moi je
craignais vraiment que j'allais finir
lesquin pour nous les noirs il ya
beaucoup moins de racisme ici qu'aux
états unis
[Musique]
et pour rappeler harlem au noir
américain de paris conquis par la
baguette de pain et le paquet de
gauloises il y aura toujours la voie
d'une mais mercer
[Musique]
au bas mot 10
niveaux
d'albi
[Musique]